welcome to D LM model lifestyle I'm
Daniel and in this video we are gonna
talk about twelve clothing hacks for men
so let's get right into the video
all right if this is your first time on
my channel subscribe and click the
notification belt so it won't miss any
of the next videos now let's start with
the first hack roll up your sleeves if
you roll up your sleeves you look more
manly and rugged but it looks better if
you roll it up without a tie so if you
don't wear a tie roll up those sleeves
it also looks nice if you wear it with a
nice watch because it just complements
the watch and it just stands out a lot
more the best way to roll it up is with
the j.crew roll now let me show you how
to do that first roll it up once and
then you just roll it up again with a
little bit of the top part showing
[Music]
shorten your shoelaces shoelaces are
made to kind of fit all sizes right but
they tend to be too long for some people
so when you go and tie them they're too
long and too fluffy and it doesn't look
good at all
so just replace them with shorter ones
or make them short for yourself use
Vaseline for difficult zippers
if you struggle to unzip or zip up your
jacket or any other clothing just add a
bit of vaseline and it was if up a lot
smoother
wash and dry your clothes inside out if
you wash and dry your clothes inside out
it will last a lot longer because it is
more gentle on the side of the clothing
that the people actually seek get some
double-sided say because when you wear a
nice slim fitted shirt
sometimes you will expose your skin
especially if it's a little bit tight so
just add the double-sided tape and you
can move as much as you want without
showing any skin use water spray and a
blow dryer on a wrinkled shirt to
quickly get the wrinkles out of the
t-shirt to spray it with a little bit of
water and use a blow dryer to dry it and
the wrinkles will be gone
alright fix a wrinkled color with a flat
iron if you wear a shirt with a wrinkled
color it will just look low-quality and
just very bad so just fix it by using a
flat iron and your shirt will look a lot
better
now I know there's a lot of people that
don't wash their jeans too often I do
but if you don't like to what you can do
is put your smelly jeans in the freezer
why because the reason why your jeans
start to smell is because the bacteria
transfers from your skin to the gene and
so the low temperature of the freezer
will kill the bacteria that causes the
bad smell
all right what can you do about shrink
clothes all you got to do is use fabric
conditioner and water to unshrink them
how do you do it
just mix the water and fabric
conditioner in a bowl then soak your
shrink clothes in it for around 15
minutes then just stretch it out and
leave it to dry
[Music]
used dryer sheets now you can use used
dried use use use use dryer sheets to
remove the white stains underneath your
arms you can also try and use this guy
Navia from an invisible black hole why
I've been using this for years and I
never get those yellow white ugly stains
on my clothes a lot them for you in a
video description so you can go and
check them out
alright now you know when you're walking
and your shoelaces just becomes undone
or they loosen so what can you do about
it just tie them the other way around
let me show you most guys tie their
shoelaces this way around right but over
time your boat goes vertical and it also
starts to loosen now this is how you
want to tie the first step is the same
second step is also the same but now
instead of going over the loop you go
under it and pull the lace through now
you're bold tighten as you walk instead
of getting loose the bow will also lay
nicely across the shoe
[Music]
now you know when you have those nice
pair of shoes but they are just
uncomfortable or if you buy new ones and
you have to kind of get used to them you
get blisters and well that sometimes
happens with certain shoes right so what
can you do about it well just get some
sneaker inserts they are so comfortable
and you can wear them with all your
shoes I thought of them for you in the
video description down below so you can
go and check them out as well that's it
guys thank you so much for watching if
you liked it give it a like subscribe
and click the notification ballot so you
won't miss any new views that's it
Cheers
you